passwords are by far the most common
type of user authentication
they are popular because the theory
makes perfect sense to individuals and
is reasonably simple to implement for
developers
on the other hand poorly constructed
passwords can pose security flaws
a well-designed password-based
authentication process does not save the
user's actual password this would make
it far too simple for a hacker or a
malevolent insider to access all of the
system's user accounts
in this video you will learn how to
crack passwords and simultaneously try
to make your passwords as brute force
resistant as possible let's take a look
at the topics to be covered today
we start by learning about what is
password tracking in general
next we take a look at the different
techniques of password cracking that
hackers use in order to generate user
credentials for hacking
moving on we take a look at the multiple
tools that hackers can use to generate
these hashes and the passwords
finally we take a look at the steps and
the guidelines that users can follow to
prevent their passwords from being
cracked
let's start by giving a basic idea about
password cranking
password cracking is the process of
identifying an unknown password to a
computer or network resource using a
program code
it can also assist a threat actor in
gaining illegal access to resources
malicious actors can engage in various
criminal activities with the information
obtained through password tracking the
procedure might entail comparing a set
of words to guest credentials or using
an algorithm to guess the password
repeatedly password tracking can be done
for several reasons but the most
malicious reason is in order to gain
unauthorized access to a computer
without the owner's awareness
this results in cyber crime such as
stealing passwords for the purpose of
accessing banking information other
non-malicious reasons for password
cracking occur when someone has
misplaced or forgotten a password
another example of non-malicious
password cracking may take place if a
system administrator is conducting tests
on password strength as a form of
security test this enables so that the
hacker cannot easily access protected
systems the best way that users can
protect their passwords from cracking is
to ensure that they choose strong
passwords
typically passwords must contain a
combination of mixed case random letters
digits and symbols
strong passwords should never be actual
words
in addition strong passwords are at
least eight characters long in many
password protected applications users
are notified of the strength of the
password they have chosen upon entering
it the user can then modify it and
strengthen the password based on the
indications of its strength
now that we understand the basics of
password cracking let's go to the basic
techniques hackers use to retrieve
passwords from general victims
asking the customer for their password
is simple approach to hacking a phishing
email directs the unwary reader to a
counterfeit login page linked with
whatever service the hacker wants to
access generally by demanding the user
fix some critical security flaw or aid
in a database reset
that page then captures their password
which the hacker can subsequently
exploit for their own purpose
social engineering influences the victim
to get personal information such as bank
account numbers or passwords
the strategy is popular among hackers
because they realize that humans are the
gateway to vital credentials and
information
through social engineering the employee
tried and true tactics to exploit and
influence age-old human tendencies
rather than devising novel means to
breed secure and advanced technologies
it has been demonstrated that many firms
either lack adequate security or are
overly friendly and trustworthy even
they should not be
they allow granting access to critical
facilities based on a uniform or a sob
story
a hacker searches a password dictionary
for the correct password in the case of
a dictionary attack
password dictionaries cover many themes
and of mixture of topics such as
politics movies and music groups user's
failure to create a strong password is
why this approach efficiently cracks
passwords till today
simply said this assault employs the
same terms that many individuals use as
passwords a hacker can compare the
password hash obtained to hashes of the
password dictionaries to find the
correct plain text password
now that the passwords have been hashed
the hackers attempt to achieve
authentication by breaking the password
hash they accomplish this by applying a
rainbow table which is a set of
precomputed hashes of portable password
combinations
hackers can use the rainbow table to
crack the hash resulting in guessing
your password
as a result it retrieves the password
hash from the system and eliminates any
need to break it
furthermore it does not necessitate the
discovery of the password itself
the breach is accomplished if the hash
matches
in a brute force assault the attacker
attempts multiple password combinations
until the correct one is identified
the attacker uses software to automate
this process and run exhaustive password
combination in a substantially shorter
length of time
with the growth of hardware and
technology in recent years such programs
have been invigorated
it won't be quick if your password is
more than a few characters lengthy but
it will eventually reveal your password
brute force assaults can be sped up by
throwing more processing resources at
them
with so many different techniques coming
together to correct passwords none of
them are useful without the right tools
there are a plethora of scripts and
snippets of code that can retrieve
passwords from either encrypted storage
or from the hash digest
let's go through some of these tools
kane and able is a password recovery
tool for microsoft operating systems
it allows easy recovery of various kinds
of passwords by sniffing the network
cracking encrypted passwords using
dictionary brute force and crypt
analysis attacks
recording vibe conversations decoding
scrambled passwords recovering wireless
network keys etc are some of the other
features of k enable
the latest version is faster and
contains a lot of new features like arp
poison routing which enables sniffing on
switched lands and man-in-the-middle
attacks
the sniffer in this version can also
analyze encrypted protocols such as ssh1
and https while containing filters to
capture credentials from a wide range of
authentication mechanisms
it also ships routing protocol
authentication monitors and route
extractors
dictionary and brute force crackers are
also present along with common hashing
algorithms and several specific
authentications password hash
calculators and other features
john the ripper is a password tracking
application that was first released in
1996 for unix-based computers
it was created to evaluate password
strength brute force encrypted hash
passwords and break passwords using
dictionary attacks
it can use dictionary attacks rainbow
tables and other attacks depending on
the target type
rainbow crack is a password tracking
application that uses time memory
trade-off algorithm to crack password
hashes with rainbow tables
rainbow tables make password cracking
more easier and faster than traditional
brute force attacks it is like a
dictionary containing nearly every
possible password and the pre-calculated
hashes
treating this kind of dictionary takes
much more time than cracking a single
hash but after that you can use the same
dictionary over and over again
this procedure might take a long time
however once the table is ready it can
break passwords far quicker than brute
force methods
with so many tools ready to nab our
passwords there are certain set of rules
users can follow to protect their
credentials from being compromised
let's cover some of these guidelines
longer passwords are required making the
brute force mechanism tougher to
implement
longer passwords and passphrases have
been demonstrated to boost security
significantly
however it is still critical to avoid
lengthier passwords that have previously
been hacked or that feature often in
cracking dictionaries
this password policy encourages users to
establish passwords that do not contain
personal information
as previously said most users create
passwords utilizing personal information
such as hobbies nicknames pet or family
member names etc
if a hacker has access to personal
information about a specific user for
example via social media they will test
password combinations based on that
knowledge
password regulations should compel users
to distinguish between security and
convenience
users should be prohibited from using
the same password for all services
password sharing between users including
those who work in the same department or
use the same equipment should be avoided
a single breached password doesn't
affect your other accounts with this
policy
some password regulations necessitate
the creation of a pass phrase rather
than a password
while passphrases serve the same
objective the length make them more
difficult to break
in addition to letters a good pass
should include numbers and symbols
passwords may be easier for users to
remember than pass phrases however the
latter is much more breach resistant
two-factor authentication or 2fa can
help secure an online account or even a
smartphone
2fa does this by asking the user to
provide two forms of information a
password or a personal identification
pin
and a code texture to the user's
smartphone or a fingerprint before
accessing whatever is secured
this helps discourage unauthorized
entries to an account without the
original owner's permission
hope you learned something new today if
you have any questions about the topic
please feel free to ask us your queries
in the comment section below and we will
get back to you as soon as possible
subscribe to our channel for more videos
like this and thank you for watching
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here